je peux revenir
si j'ai bien compris il y a pleins de
santé de prison tu es rentré dans la
cage et du MMA avant avant
alors là il fait jour parce que comme il
vient de dire gris il fait jour je suis
un interviewer sérieux
tu connais Jean-Marie
les combats les assurances combien de
temps combien d'années de prison de 5 la
lentement pour lui que pour toi
et du coup donc en fait le
celui avec un italien et en promenade je
voulais l'appeler et m'entendait pas
parce qu'il parlait et vraiment c'était
je l'ai fait vraiment pour rigoler avec
les collègues comme si je l'appelais
j'avais deux options j'ai dit mange la
pizza
soit j'ai envoyé de l'Opéra j'ai envoyé
en mode vraiment les trois
vraiment pour m'amuser et la cellule à
côté il entendait Papa chanteur
attends et donc et donc et donc au
placard déjà
tu reçois
[Applaudissements]
et donc tu as pris 5 ans voilà plusieurs
peines et la dernière peine où je
découvre la voix et là j'ai arrêté et je
me suis consacré vraiment dans la
musique et là tu es là alors aujourd'hui
[Rires]
je demande
c'est un ami les gens polyvalents
on a préparé donc autour de l'histoire
de ma vie un projet à 360 degrés donc le
livre la comédie musicale donc à
Montréal je pars cette semaine
un spectacle on commence en janvier à
Paris pendant deux mois
un seul en scène
et c'est pas disponible
et voilà donc le titre qui est sorti à
15 jours c'est ça qui a fait un beau
petit carton donc je suis vraiment
content et on continue un bombarde à
fond on est heureux pour toi merci merci
beaucoup